um okay three plus two
three plus two is something we can do
and we finally get white okay
let's go one e4 then c5
so what is uh the fancy way here
okay let's try b4
and h3
it does not exactly lose even goes d5
then i guess we
take queen takes d5 knight f3
and i think e5 is a move here
yeah and c4
i think i first uh first saw this idea
in a game of
a very very talented ukrainian green
master uh
yarothobjerbook
who was sort of my uh
a good friend when i was young
then i think he moved to us and uh
he's doing reasonably well but he does
not
play chess that often anymore okay maybe
rookie one fishing for some
d4 one day
goes b7 so can we
can we take on before and then
come up with something
okay if you don't try you will never
find um find out
he simply castles okay
nicest three looks normal queen g6 is
probably the idea
i could probably just win a queen by the
way by playing d3
queen g6 knight h4
but knight s3 is kind of a move that you
play
that you play quickly yeah queen five is
still there and um
it will be there after uh d3 as well
okay now that we missed
three queen
so how should we play this should we
sacrifice b4
or uh or we just go
b5
after b5 he wants to play knight d4
and we can just play it slow somehow
like d3
it's way more tempting to play something
aggressive like d4 but i failed to
fail to make it work and all the lines
pretty much
which is not the reason not to play it
by the way who really cares
those bishop takes before
um
i think bishop d3 is supposed to be
our idea that does not really exist
but we still don't care
maybe it's actually time to care we're
sort of lost here
on the other hand even if we are lost
why would we care
that's pretty much how i think during uh
during the game
okay so maybe rook takes now
okay it's very bad anyway so whatever i
play
it's not a very big mistake
knight takes e4 knight xc4 is kind of
kind of acceptable we have some
compensation there definitely
knight g5 is a threat and d5 is also
coming
so maybe bishop takes this three is a
move
but then we will play some rock h4
and at least he will be scared for like
one move
queen d7 seems forced to me
and then we go bishop g5 i thought
so this was my big point like bishop a1
bishop takes f6
and we pretend we have an attack but
maybe we do actually
maybe we actually do
we should play one bishop f6 here and
now
something like ah he just takes okay
then i think we can
take on h7 and go queen d2
yeah i don't see what's wrong with it to
be honest so you go to g7 and queen
detour quincy one
maybe queen c1 just to like if we
blunder something we'll take
a1 one day
no we're not blundering okay let's go
queen d2
there is no big difference but queens
one is sort of a chicken of trying to
keep an eye on a1 we don't need this
bishop we want to checkmate
and i think we will i think i can
actually promote queen h6 here
so there is literally no move for him to
stop this
okay i promote queen h6
i don't even see a weird way like queen
h3 it's still queen h6 and so on
it was actually a cool game by uh by
anthea that's how we play chess we
basically don't care then we don't care
again
then like if we don't resign we
checkmate in a
in a nice way
yeah he resigns okay nice game